she
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's week three it's nfl you just tapped
into the squad ride presented by
draftkings live in the bleacher report
app that's right my name is connor
rogers alongside the man of the people
he's always got the good stuff to give
away greg ivory greg how we feeling i
know you got something in your pocket to
hand out already
connor feeling great and you know
what i got in my pocket i got hoodies i
got jerseys but i also have the handy
dandy ipad right here for the people
that don't know this is how you get the
jerseys this is how you get the hoodies
it all happens right here in the handy
dandy ipad connor i am in the comments
right now i am in the comments i have
i'm a pizza ship i'm a pizza ship
he has the the nick chub the nick chubb
gif
shout out to the username and shout out
to the gift rocking with nick chubb
today oh my god it just went away there
it is there it is though connor uh i
love that i'm a pizza ship i'm a pizza
[ __ ]
walking away with the first hoodie today
this is the show where we bet anytime
touchdown scores chosen by you the squad
last week we rode with oscar 19
parkinson and christian mccaffrey worked
out pretty well it hit we had a slow
week one whatever we had a hot week too
mccaffrey got in the end zone on the
ground he got in the end zone through
the air last weekend so on friday we
asked you on social and in the app drop
your locks to score a touchdown and
these are the most popular picks you
sent us no surprise at the top derrick
henry coming off a monster weekend
travis kelsey's already found the end
zone three times this year dk metcalf
looking to get back on the board saquon
barkley has not scored this year
surprising surprising but he's got the
falcons so you should feel a little
better about his bounce back this
weekend a couple top flight wide
receivers and a guy in t.j hockinson
that should see a good target share for
a struggling lions team so with that
being said we got a ton of great videos
from you last week can't feature them
all but we have to show you a couple of
the good ones
this is last week i'm taking it this
week it's a lock every week top lock and
drop you here
and it's heads darren waller
derek henry travis kelsey anytime
touchdown scored minus 150. lock it in
every week let's make some money let's
make come on boys
let's make some money greg i know you
got the hoodies but what else are you
giving away today
connor i'm not only giving out hoodies
today i'm also giving away two not one
but two nfl jersey gift cards one goes
to the winning the winner of the uh lock
legend contest that we're gonna do and
one goes to a lucky lucky commenter so
get in the comments and do what you do
if you need a jersey if you need a
hoodie i need gifts i need emojis but
connor
i need winners
only
please connor
please say to please too please all
right we have four legendary picks to
show you you know the deal by now the
last one standing is the squad ride
leader they get the jersey and they get
the street cred because they are picking
who's getting in the end zone and that
thing is getting boosted in draftkings
it doesn't get any better than that it's
time for round one our first pitch comes
from ryan.54
ryan tell us who's scoring a touchdown
today
all right we got monday night football
we got the eagles the cowboys
[Music]
we're going to ask him
for marty cooper right hand for devonta
smith who's scoring touchdown
right hand davonte smith it is let's go
i think uh ryan out there just walking
around disney world asking for locks
bold strategy but a nice pick in devonta
smith and as always we need to find a
challenger for ryan so we're going out
and looking for one from den harding
matt with our second pitch of the day
let's see what it is matt
all right we got three tennis balls we
got tj hawkinson travis kelsey right
here
and george kittle
we're gonna rip it at the fence
whichever ball gets stuck in the fence
scoring a touchdown this weekend all
right
all right here we go
it's a lot
all right you heard the first two
pitches greg you're riding with the
disney bear legend or matt the tennis
legend showing off some athleticism to
the squad ride this weekend
kinda have a question actually i want to
make a bet
i'll bet you a hundred dollars if you
can tell me who that disney character is
in that first video oh man odds plus a
million i have no idea
i have literally no idea who that is but
i do know about the pick devonta smith
taking on the cowboys today uh i like to
pick plus 150 you know what we can do
here
as well tj hawkinson uh
shout out to the tennis legend love the
video
you know it took it took that took
practice you know or something or a
couple yeah it spoke to me a couple
takes maybe maybe one maybe two maybe
three well you know no but shouts out to
the to the to the video but
i'm leaning towards devonta smith i
don't know connor what about you which
which way are you leaning man i like the
tennis video better but i'm leaning
towards the devonta smith's pick more i
think that game is going to be a
shootout we're going to talk about that
game even more later i look at it i feel
pretty good about davonte smith
especially plus money plus money there
but
doesn't matter what you or i think it's
up to the people how are they deciding
this one
connor i am in the comments right here
i'm in the handy dandy uh seeing a lot
of gifts seeing a lot of gifts shout out
to red white and saint blue red white
and st lou they got tyler murray even
though that has nothing to do with what
we're talking about but brother you're
here so i'm giving you a hoodie shout
out to you red white saint lou uh here
we go i got
d geek d geek the legend d geek is in
the comments saying hocketton definitely
shout out to you d geek
walking away with a hoodie uh siraj
siraj j
4 4 says winner's only please and he has
a gift of tj
so connor people are going against us
they're going against us but you know
what i'm vibing with it why not it
appears the people have spoken the
tennis legend tj hawkinson moving on to
the next round i'm okay with that the
first round goes to den harding
matt the tennis legend with tj hawkinson
but
he's still got two challengers remaining
that you have to get through so on to
round two on to round two our next pitch
comes from a familiar one w trammell we
got w tremble
buttercup's gonna give us a lock
who is it buttercup
dk metcalf i don't think so where's she
going
travis kelsey lock it in
travis
kelsey from buttercup all right you
heard from the buttercup legend
craig who you riding with this is tough
i'm not going against the dog there man
look at this you got the tennis legend
you got the buttercup swim legend we
like kelsey this week who are you riding
well with i give my take what i need
everybody to do is get in the comments
and let us know if you're riding with
travis kelsey in the buttercup legend or
tj hawkinson in the tennis legend i want
to talk about the buttercup legend what
a what a cute name buttercup what a cute
name
but the swimming execution connor there
was no no no speed no urgency no
straight
so no urgencies just straight vibing
actually i like that i like you know
what i'm winning myself over right now i
like the vibes in the video i like the
the the the doggy paddle and i like to
pick travis kelsey
and you know what we can do here with
the minus 140 so i might be leaning this
way connor which way are you leaning
it's not even a contest here i'm going
with the butter
cup legend the swim the dog legend i
don't pick against the dogs on this show
you know that every single week there's
a dog video i'm not picking against it i
love the pic love the travis kelsey pick
let's get that to some plus money that
would be fun right all right what do the
people think though this one
connor i am back into the comments i'm
back on the handy dandy uh
the comments are flying brother they are
flying right now i got
i got jackboy37 says buttercup knows the
locks shout out to you jackboy37 you are
walking away with the hoodie uh i also
have
i also have joseph
magana joseph magana has a travis kelsey
gift there it is
you gotta see it travis kelsey gift uh
so shout out to you
i got one i'm gonna give away one more
i'm gonna give away one more here we go
this is funny 22 cody says you're the
only you're the winner's only please but
it has a funny funny gift that says
buckle up
buttercup
buckle up buttercup so uh connor i i
think we can make a decision here
i think i think buttercup stole
everybody's i think buttercup stole
everybody's heart like in the comments i
mean it stole your heart i mean it won
me over
how could it not he shouts out the
buttercup buttercup not no try hard
personality buttercup just doggy padding
along getting the pick getting a lot
yeah that's it second round belongs to w
trammell but he's got to defeat our
final contender to take home the jersey
take home the title of the squad ride
leader winner takes it all final round
let's do it next up is sean stone 5-1-4
let's see the pick sean you got a tough
one tough competition here against
buttercup
all right you heard from the race car
legend going with derrick henry it did
not work for us week one but if you had
him in fantasy week two
you probably won the man almost put up
50 points in ppr so
this is tough man
i like trap i'm excited about the travis
kelsey pick i love the race car
execution of that there
craig who you rolling with i don't even
know where to go with this one
connor this one's tough
let me let me talk to the people because
you know i i taps in with the people
and i want them to tell us i want them
to tell me which way should we ride
should we go
travis kelsey
in the buttercup legend or should we go
derek henry
in the car legend you guys please let me
know because i am contemplating conor is
also contemplating i believe uh
i i i don't know but i'll talk about the
video connor i will talk about the video
legendary i mean tournament style bro
tournament style legendary he got his
winner by tournament style just just
just him throwing the tournament style
into the video is legendary in itself i
don't know if you've ever been with your
friends and you guys want to play video
games and it was a bunch of you you guys
always would probably play the
tournaments though suggest the
tournament style play you gotta make a
bracket so shout out to my guy for uh
the car legend for that uh but connor
what's like do you have a take on any
like which do you have a take on
anything where are you leaning yeah i
listen not easy
i'm going with buttercup man i love the
travis kelsey pig i think it's going to
be a shootout against the chargers i
could see each of those quarterbacks
throwing three touchdowns in that game
kelsey feels like he scores every week
he has scored both weeks already this
season this is not new with him he's
done it for years now with the best
quarterback in the league
man i'm i'm going with kelsey i'm going
with buttercup i'm going with the big
swim but
carter we're not deciding the squad ride
leader man let the comments tell us i
was just who were boosting
i was just i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm i'm
just so
amped like right now because you just
mentioned the quarterback that throws
the travis kelsey in that quarterback is
all my fantasy team so therefore in for
a big week i'm also
i'm also leaning with you towards
buttercup but it's not up to me it's not
up to you connor let me get into these
comments let me get into these comments
because this is how we're going to
decide the winner here um buttercup is
getting a lot of love i see ashley
guerrero ashley guerrero says can we
pick both shout out to you ashley for
the vibes i wish we could pick po i wish
we could pick both those are good vibes
uh moving on moving on
he said i uh can't guard can't guard cut
says i had him in fantasy week two so
i'm rocking with my boy king henry it's
a lock he had him in that weak connor he
had him in that big week hey shout out
to you can't guard cut you are walking
away with a hoodie one more connor i'll
be generous here one more uh
i got
jack boy is back in the comments shout
out to jack boy uh
here we go next one i see connor because
the comments are literally flowing right
now the next one i see i'm just gonna
okay here we go ben mack ben mack a lot
ben mcelott got a ride with buttercup
has the travis kelsey gift therefore you
know what that means connor we got a new
squad ride leader
buttercup
travis kelsey my boy w trammell
you are the winner of this week's
squad ride
uh yeah so i mean shout out to you guys
shout out to buttercup shout out to
travis kelsey let's go get a touchdown
man we are right ding connor
man
also
also also
fill up this graphic let me show you
guys
let me show you guys something connor
you want to see some magic let's get it
done look at the graphics the graphic is
right there you see travis kelsey minus
140. poof
there it is guys see it that's what we
do here us here on on uh squad ride show
that's what we do uh thanks to our
friends at draftkings we're gonna boost
that from minus 140 to plus 100 check
the br betting socials for
a link to the odds will send us your
screenshots of your bets let's get rich
this sunday connor let's get rich let's
like we got to put the vibes out into
the atmosphere let's get rich send us
your videos and your celebrations we
want winners and winners only
please let's do it shout out buttercup
the new lock legend all right we're not
done yet we got more locks to talk
cody's to give away you still have a
jersey to give away we know the squad
ride leader buttercup better get that
jersey by the way not whoever
buttercup's owner is all right
community comment contest you all saw it
last week it was the talk of the betting
world a 16 leg parlay he hit the first
15 going into monday night football
needed that lions upset looked fun in
the first quarter everything went
downhill from there but
if it did anything greg it inspired you
and i to make our own 16 leg parlay for
this week sir and earlier this week in
the app we asked for your takes on it
let's take a look at what we built
people had to say about it all right
there it is we already got carolina so
we're not out yet we got one in the
books a lot of ball game left across the
board here we do have two upsets nothing
crazy but the rams beating the bucks
and the giant the falcons taking down
the giants and then a board with a lot
of favorites i want to know what the
people were saying about it greg
yeah i need you guys to get in the
comments and tell me what you guys think
of our parlay
i'm giving out hoodies we also asked you
in the app earlier this week
let's take a look at the first app
comment from david zim
93
let's take a look at the comment connor
uh loving our parlay right here actually
if you guys aren't rocking with us uh
get with the program there's david zim's
comment right there connor he says swap
that eagles cowboys pig
swap that eagles cowboys pig
let's move on to the next one let's move
on to the next one uh from ska
older or scolder soldier yeah that's
what it is soldier 22x says minnesota is
winning at home
wow
minnesota is winning at home taking on
russell wilson uh in that seattle team
that is very very very very bold uh
connor
what is your take on these
man listen the first one i get it it's
it's the eagles it's the cowboys it can
be a pick em any single week it's it's
not easy both teams always play up to
each other i like our pick with dallas
i'm sticking with it i feel good about
it i believe in dak prescott at the end
of the day that's what matters most but
i get that one the second one
probably no dalvin cook from minnesota
today the seahawks
they're coming off a loss which means
they're gonna be ready to go today
they're not gonna spiral out of control
i know they're on the road it makes
things tough but listen that line is
really close
russell wilson's got it the defensive
will step up we got to see if minnesota
will be able to run the ball still so
the first one i get but we're not
changing it the second one i am not on
the vikings right now
what are the people thinking of the
parlay and these comments
yeah connor we're we're not changing the
first one uh
no second one was kind of outrageous but
i am in the comments i am in the
comments uh brandon s12 says mac jones
is gonna shred the saints shout out to
you for saying that john this is gonna
stretch the states uh i got uh
cody ruckus says stefan dick's catching
two tds today you heard it here first
people are just in the comments just
giving out their takes just just popping
off takes uh
so everybody that i'm i'm naming you
guys are walking away with hoodies uh
but connor i'm gonna just make a
decision i'm gonna just make a decision
because everybody in the comments is
just popping off takes i'ma just i'm
gonna pick somebody who's gonna win i'm
gonna go with david zim david zim 93
just for the vibes i mean the comment
was was outrageous but
why not just for the vibes uh we're
gonna we're gonna hook you up with a
hoodie
oh man say something nuts and you still
might walk away as a winner which is
what we're about to win we're about to
drop our boldest bets of the week and
hopefully
we do win
greg what do we need from the people
right now before we get into our boldest
bets
get in the comments and tell me whether
you are riding with me
what you probably should or if you're
riding with my guy over there my guy
connor looking real spiffy
look at real spiffy is that peach man
that's peach you got on a little peach
today bringing it back for the squad ah
yes yes sir oh man all right um let's
see these boldest bats honor i'll take
it away connor yeah yeah connor who who
who who you got man who who you coming
at me with this week man my my three leg
parlay lost by one chase claypool catch
last week hit on the other two things
chase clip pulled me to four catches he
got three so i'm gonna kind of dumb
things down focus on one guy that is
mike williams on the chargers but i'm
still getting crazy these are bold bets
for a reason greg i'm saying mike
williams catches or rushes he's but he's
going to catch him two touchdowns
against the chiefs he's done this he's
caught two touchdowns in four career
games so mike williams he's been here
before and those odds are crazy boosted
to plus 12 hundred
it's not it's been done before he's done
this plenty of times justin herbert's
been feeding him it looks like the
breakout year from mike williams let's
make some money what do you say what do
you got
connor here we go here we go i love the
long shot love the long shot but uh you
were really close last week i need to
see one go in and i strongly believe
in the prime time matchup
niners packers
there's a running back on the niners
team by the name of trey sermon and uh
he's gonna get some playing time today
so what i think he's gonna what with him
getting playing time i also think he's
gonna score
but i'm changing this i'm changing this
all you i know you guys can place that
bet trey sermon to score place that one
if you want to but if you go to
draftkings and you add the niners to win
with him to score it's plus 250 this one
is gonna hit i'm telling you trey sermon
is gonna get in the end zone the niners
are gonna run the ball against that
green bay defense
and he's gonna get those opportunities
so i'm rocking with trace irving to
score and the niners to win
what i want to know right now is who are
people riding with they going to me a
little crazy mike williams two
touchdowns are going with your parlay
trey sermon and the niners win and i
know you still have a jersey to give
away to that exact comment section what
are they saying
all right here we go we're going to mix
it in with good vibes and a little bit
bad vibe because we got to show the bad
vibes love that's the only way we're
going to get them on the good side so
here we go uh
ben mack killer ben macaleps says
mike williams ain't getting one that is
okay ben that is okay
connor that is okay watch this watch
this connor ben you're walking away with
a hoodie now he probably might change
his mind connor so shout out to you ben
uh we're moving on i have ny fan 98
eckler going to get way more
opportunities than williams
all right there's going to get way more
opportunities than williams okay
it's a fair fair take shout out to you
ny fan now about both walking away
with a hoodie uh
yeah how about both yeah exactly uh here
we go
i mean
they're they're in the comments man
sean stone514 says kirk cousins anytime
tv connor i have a jersey to give away
don't i
yeah you do kirk cousins anytime
i mean that kirk cousins running i'll be
shot
forward shout outs yeah yeah i think
that that's when he said sean stone514
we're giving him a hoodie for that take
connor please i i hope you hit
i hope you hey that'll be big odds big
odds on that um
i have a jersey to give away so how
about i give it away now please i'm in
the comments
and i see goat garden goat garden
goat garden it says
two touchdowns today for your pit connor
he's sending you good vibes mike
williams two touchdowns that's right the
goat garden
you are walking away
with a jersey a jersey
go garden gets jersey jersey gift card
it's even better than just a jersey
well done well done all right
good luck with your wagers everyone hope
you had fun today i know we did as
always we do this every single week 11
a.m eastern time greg i know greg gets
up a little early he's on the west coast
shout out to greg congrats all our
hoodie and jersey winners if you won br
benning will dm you in the next 24 hours
not me not great we'd love to but it's
going to be br betting they're going to
take care of you thank you to everyone
that commented comment section has been
awesome you're the reason that we can do
this show and the way it's done thanks
to our legends ryan 54 dan harding matt
w trammell sean stone514 the race legend
shout out to buttercup though
buttercup's the real hero the real og of
the show enjoy your football sunday
buttercup drop your real time whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
something else
yeah hoodies back to the comments hey
joe yan shout out to joe yeah he got the
go gift going on i got not not mitch
trubisky says sterling shepherd is a lot
to score shout out to you not mr bisky
you're walking away with hoodie i have
west mess
420 uh west mess 420 says two touchdowns
he's rocking with you connor and mike
williams score two touchdowns
i got one more hoodie in me jason wade
13. jason wade 13 he's shouting out deke
geek in the comments we all know deep
geek is a squad ride legend so shout out
to you jason wade13 for shouting out
deep geek everybody at d geek right now
matter of fact everybody at d geek right
now shout out to you uh jason wade
you're walking away with
a hoodie it's time to get up out of here
well done alongside greg ivory i'm
connor rogers see you next week same
time same place have a good football
sunday peace
[Music]
you